hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game that took place yesterday in
round 15
of the magnus crossing invitational
preliminaries uh it's yanni pomnishi the
current leader of the feeder candidates
tournament against the 22 year old
origin argentinian grandmaster alan
pishot uh and
uh well it is quite the game so without
further ado let's check it out and then
we're going to discuss the standings a
little bit and uh well
uh well some some other some other stuff
all right so nipple with the white
pieces
opens with e4 and bishop goes for the
sicilian defense with c5
uh knight to f3 e6 and jan strikes in
the center with
d4 now we have captures captures and now
knight to c6 so just uh
naturally developing going for the time
of variation uh
knight to c3 and the queen to c7 now uh
bishop to e3 and now a6 taking away the
b5 square from
uh white's white's pieces and now queen
to f3 there are
many moves that are very popular here
bishop p2 bishop d3 you could continue
with queen to d2
but here queen to e3 somewhat rarer but
not
not extremely rare uh so queen to f3
and now we have knight to e5 and this is
a kind of breaking opening principles
but
when you are already playing at this
level it's okay to break some of them
uh the most popular way to continue is
just to continue developing
but okay knight the e5 attacking the
queen and now nepo goes for queen to g3
and this is an excellent square for the
queen
not only is it uh paralyzing the knight
the queen would be captured on c7 if the
knight moves but also it prevents black
from developing the bishop
uh the g7 pawn would hang and so on so
here
white continues with b5 it's not a
problem this all was played before so
no doubt that this is uh some excellent
preparation by black
and nepal castle's queen side uh we have
knight to f6
continuing development and now even f4
kicking away the knight we have knight e
to g4 now attacking the bishop
and now while you could bring the bishop
back to g1 it does make sense to
control the knight maybe push the knight
back with h3 later on and nipple goes
for
bishop to d2 and now comes b4 attacking
the knight and the knight is also the
defender of this pawn
uh but here it's not really a problem
yep it just goes knight to a4
and the e4 pawn cannot be captured
because the knight is now awkwardly
placed on
on g4 so that's kind of a problem so
here
although you could go for example knight
captures queen captures and
knight to f2 with an attack on the rook
and the queen uh the problem is the rook
on a8 is undefended so queen f3 with a
double attack
solves all of white's problems and white
just wins this on the spot
so instead after knight to a4 we have h5
now the knight is nicely defended
and here comes bishop to d3 there is a
game
or rather i think there are a few games
where h3 was played but here we have
bishop to d3 by nipple
and it is as of move 13 that we have a
completely new game so the bishop is
excellently placed they are defending
the e4 pawn also helping out with the
defense against some future
checkmating ideas by black maybe bishop
b7 rook c8 is going to put a lot of
pressure on c2
so here we have d uh sorry d5 by black
striking in the center could be a little
bit dangerous the black king is still in
the center of the board
but we don't have captures allowing the
knights to
uh improve uh the position but rather e5
chasing away the knight
knights the e4 and now they portrayed we
have bishop captures d
captures and h3 uh so chasing away this
knight
the knight has to go back to h6 which is
not
the most active of squares okay you
could shift it to f5 at some point
but it's hard to say if it will work and
here we have
queen to b3 by nepo nipple there
is the option of playing bishop captures
on b4 but it's such a complicated line
and it doesn't seem uh that it's a good
one or
it could be played but it's so
complicated that for a rapid game i
don't think
it's even possible to play this but i
will show it to you because it's super
fun
so if we capture on b4 and the black
captures the bishop which is what you
want to do
you're going to capture on g7 attack the
rook here we have rook to f8 and now
queen captures on h6 you win back your
piece but
bishop to d7 is coming and now what do
you do with this knight here
obviously b3 is impossible you just
create too many weaknesses just bishop
captures on a4
completely shatters white's white queen
side so you're gonna have to go for
f5 here and here uh you know all hell
breaks loose uh because
what can be done here bishop captures on
a4 black grabs a piece
f captures an e6 and this is just a very
ugly
rook to d8 now trying to remove the
defender of the c2 uh
pawn so queen captures on c2 will be
checkmate but now
rook h to f1 uh we have rook after
sunday for now threatening checkmate
uh and now e captures on f7 with check
rook captures and queen to e6
check forcing the king to move either
here or here and then uh
any capture will come with check so
queen to e7
uh seems to be best and here it's a
complete
madness uh probably nothing better for
why did then to go for this repetition
of moves after
queen the c8 check followed by queen to
e6 check so
basically uh capturing on b4 is the
fanciest way to draw the game so nepo
doesn't like this he goes queen to b3
uh puts pressure on on e6 a lot of times
prepares f5 at some point
maybe maybe g4 f5 but also
it's just uh well a very active square
for the queen so here bishop to d7
uh and now finally bishop captures on b4
now the b4 square is defended but now
rook to b8 pinning the bishop uh and
here comes the move that
uh well i'm sure nepo is very proud of
playing as
we all are and that is bishop captures
on f8 here nipple sacrifices the queen
and it's a very a very interesting
decision because black
capture the queen there is nothing
better here but now not the automatic
a capture on b3 because then you allow
black to capture your bishop first you
move the bishop which tempo the queen is
under attack
so queen to a5 the queen needs to move
and only now do we capture on b3 and now
our bishop
survives so how do you continue this
with bishop captures on a4
b captures queen captures and now not
allowing any queen to a1 ideas
bishop back to a3 and now we have this
position where
black does have compensation or
okay in this case white sacrifice so
white has compensation but black needs
to bring the knight and the rook into
the game
uh to be able to to contest for for
anything
in this game and it's not an easy task
so here uh
we have king d7 you cannot go to e7 the
bishop controls all of the dark squares
so king the d7
a brave move uh going into the line of
fire of this rook but
it's not a problem uh for the moment
there are no great discoveries so
nipple continues by bringing the other
rook into the game now you can do some
rook lifts to rookie 3 maybe rook c3
rook to b3 if needed
so king the c8 getting the king away
from
any discoveries and now rook captures an
e4
and this is not just a pawn grab the
rook will be very active here but now
now the knight cannot move as the rook
would uh would be captured so here
what you what you have to do here for
black to play this game is to simply or
continue moving the king king to b8 and
after
white starts bringing the rooks into the
game king to a8
and the the black king is surprisingly
safe here there is no way to reach the
black king and now
black will uh continue bringing the the
pieces into the game
however here after rook captures on e4
uh
bishop played rook to d8 uh but now it's
a bit of a different story now
rook to d3 and now you you are having
some problems here because if you go
king to b8 now uh there's this very
unfortunate knight the c6 check and now
you have to capture the knight otherwise
you'll lose the queen
so uh queen captures the rook captures
here with check
and now the game is completely lost for
black if king c7 you're just gonna bring
the rook to d4
uh prepare rook to c4 and there's no way
for black to
uh to save the game if king b7 just rook
to c4 you attack the queen queen to d5
you
you bring the other rook into the game
and whatever you play here now the
king is done for rook d7 check you're
you're going to play something king b8
now bishop to d6 check
you're gonna play king to a8 only move
and now for example this is checkmate so
this is only one of the lines
uh that show how the moment for playing
king the b8
is passed and black needs to find
something else so here
you should start with something like
rook to d5 as
there is really nothing nothing better
here but black tried
knight to f5 which kind of makes sense
you want to trade over this very strong
knight and
if the knight captures of course you're
gonna capture the rook here but the
position is now completely lost and
uh nipple has a winning idea uh so feel
free to pause the video here
and win the game for nepo while i give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations
on not capturing the knight and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's actually
knight captures on e6 uh it's very funny
if you go for this knight captures an f5
queen captures and then you try
something like knight to d6 check
attacking the uh the king and the queen
uh here just
rook captures on these six and after e
captures you block the past pawn
and black is perfectly fine here not
much for white two
uh to hope for but uh after this knight
to f5 nipple decided to play knight
captures on e6
and now this is completely crushing uh
this is such a such an amazing move and
it was in this position that alan pishot
immediately resigned the game
as there is nothing more uh to be done
here problem is if you capture the rook
now
then uh the rook is attacked twice rook
captures on the e8 with
check only move for black is king to b7
and now check this out
knight to c5 with a royal fork uh
white will also win the black queen king
to c7
knight captures here and after rook
captures white will be up a piece in a
completely winning end game
another thing you could do after knight
captures on e6 is try something else
but um i mean what else is there uh this
this is the threat uh the queen is
hanging and there really is no
uh there is no move here uh if rook
captures on d3 you could
try and go for some sort of a weird
endgame but after rook captures on a4
uh you simply have no compensation you
can move the rook rook d5 but still
white
i mean white is up a piece white has
more pawns it's uh
it will be pointless uh so after this
beautiful night captures an e6 move
uh bishop resigned and another brilliant
victory for for yanni ponchi who
qualifies uh
for the knockout phase of this uh very
nice tournament
that is the magnus carlson invitational
so before i forget uh here
are the uh not the standings but here
are the
pairings uh for the knockout system uh
complements of chess24
uh there you have it uh in the
quarterfinal match that will happen
today
uh we'll have uh magnus carlsen versus
lebanon yanni palmichu will be facing
hikaru nakamura
wesley saw will be facing alireza firuja
and maxine vasherlag will be facing
anishigiri
so it's going to be it's going to be
pretty wild here
uh unfortunately there is no way for us
to have a magnus
hikaru final if it uh if it would ever
come to that
but it is possible to have uh for
example a magnus wesley so final uh
again it's possible to have a magnus
firuja finally it's possible to have uh
uh
nippon nishi ferugi and promising wesley
so so it could
happen you know anything uh okay we
could also have like an anishigiri
wesley sew final so
anything can happen uh but i know how
much you guys enjoy
at uh seeing magnus and hikari in the
final so unfortunately for this
tournament
this will not be an option uh well sorry
about that uh
so yeah that's the game i hope you guys
enjoyed it and
another special congratulations to
everyone who found this knight captures
an e6 move just a
spectacular spectacular idea uh i would
like to thank scott melis lokasteokaris
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to my previous
videos here
uh here thank you all for watching and i
will see you soon
continuing with the knockout phase of
the tournament
see you soon guys